la fête de la musique concerts en tous
genres pour tous les goûts tous les
styles le principe de base est toujours
respecté toutes les manifestations sont
gratuites
l'occasion aussi de rencontrer de
surprises reportage stéphanie péré
stéphane taponier le coeur en fête
la voix est toujours grave et cassée et
le poète toujours aussi fou suis-je d'un
filet l'a lui-même a donné le la de
cette fête de l'air où le vent
majeur par inadvertance
[ __ ] t'as le soleil quitte frisant des
milliers de visages
c'est beau comme un lever de coquelicots
dans un champ de tournesols il parle il
parle beaucoup il bouge beaucoup et avec
lui le public de tous les âges j'adore
et ses pairs les simples 1 10% police a
encore pas utile a single on a bien
calculé un concert sur les marches de
l'assemblée nationale higelin et le
turbulent de 59 ans s'amuse du symbole
pendant les répétitions aux côtés de
laurent fabius le président de
l'assemblée il improvise l'une de ses
facéties dont il a le secret ça
peut-être un symbole c'est ça le symbole
je n'ai concitoyens à se mettre demain
sans être obligé de s'entraîner
mais quand même
qui protège le bras
après michelin sur cette même scène
changement de registre dans quelques
minutes
ce sera une autre voie plus âpre plus
douce celle de cheb mami et de son rap
raï qui prolongera la fête tard très
tard dans la nuit